mama gassion à va être très simple bon
sens monsieur bonsoir madame c'est quoi
votre problème avec les musulmans en
france la question est claire c'est bien
j'aime bien je n'ai aucun problème avec
les musulmans en france
en fait si je vous pose cette question
c'est parce que vous avez tenu un
certain nombre de propos qui pour moi
pose vraiment problème notamment sur la
question du voile à l'école sur la
question de l'apprentissage de l'arabe
comme l'a rappelé tout à leur existence
lui voulait souvent que les images on
est pas mal alors lors d'une interview
accordée à rtl vous avez été interrogé
au sujet du voile et vous avez évoqué
votre projet d'un référendum pour savoir
s'il fallait interdire le voile dans la
rue
regardez vous avez une vision sexistes
contraire à l'égalité des sexes est ce
qu'on accepte qu'une femme soit promener
en laisse par son mari dans la rue non
et bien le voile est un signe de
soumission et moi je proposais jeu nous
avons toujours proposé debout la france
l'interdiction du port du voile dans les
hôpitaux dans les services publics à
l'université dans la rue dans la rue je
pense qu'on ne peut pas le faire sans un
référendum mais vous avez vous voyez
rejoindre sur les français alors fais à
votre question
moi j'aime parce que la question est
claire mais non elle est simple alors
non mais la question elle est plus que
justifiée quand on vous entend comparer
le voile d'une femme musulmane à un
chien qu'on promène en laisse
excusez moi mais ça ça dénote quand même
que vous avez un certain problème avec
la visibilité des communautés musulmanes
en france et de ce que peut représenter
le signe religieux qu'elle le voit le le
voile des femmes
il faut justifier là tu vois je veux
dire j'ai pas de problème tout en
comparant une femme musulmane à une
chienne en fait je voudrais qu'on
confonde pas deux choses et moi
j'aimerais vous poser une question
suite qu'est ce que vous appelez
islamophobie moi je n'ai aucun problème
avec les musulmans comme avec les
catholiques tome avec les juifs qui
pratiquent leur foi dans le respect des
lois de la république
c'est tout en revanche j'estime qu'à une
séparation que c'est le miracle de la
france c'est que les religions eux
respectent et obéissent aux lois
politiques il n'ya pas d'islam politique
et les catholiques ont dû se plier à ça
ce fut rude 1905 ce fut rude
les les congrégations fermer la loi la
séparation il ya eu des débats terrible
napoléon l'a fait avec les juifs quand
il a imposé
l'aide que devait signer tous les
rabbins de france ce fut terrible
difficile et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
ya deux catégories de visions
différentes de l'islam en france il ya
la vision de la grande majorité des
musulmans en france des français qui
sont musulmans qui bien évidemment
respecte totalement les lois de la
république
et puis à une minorité à peu active dont
vous faites partie qui est dans un
dernier sondage ifop c'était intéressant
de la fondation jean jaurès donc
fondation jean jaurès une fondation de
gauche bien pensante tout ce qu'il faut
il ya quand même 27 % des musulmans
interrogés qui estime que la charia
devrait s'imposer au dessus de la loi de
la république
et là on est à une point de friction et
moi je dis que il faut pas confondre les
musulmans les français musulmans et ceux
qui défendent un islam politique qui
changerait radicalement la société
française on sait s'il était franchi des
routes je finis les reer ou faiza quand
je vois quand je vois j'ai regardé parce
que j'ai su puisque vous l'avez écrit
sur le bandeau quand j'attendais donc
j'ai regardé je suis désolé et quand je
vois que vous dites charlie hebdo
je comprends qu'on soit pas charlie je
comprends qu'ils aient 38 % des gens qui
soient pas charlie et c'était un truc
abominable charlie hebdo qui
critiquaient la religion et tout je suis
effaré
quand je vois vous crient ils à tours
jamais vois pas ce que ça veut dire que
c'était beaucoup plus que 38 quand on
commence comme ça ça veut dire quoi
l'essence de la france c'est la phrase
de voltaire on peut être en désaccord
complet avec ce qu écrit charlie hebdo
on peut être en désaccord complet avec
ce que dit à un humoriste de france
inter sur jésus le matin à l'antenne on
peut être en désaccord complet avec
toute vision toute critique de la
religion mais on l'accès parce que la
france est le pays de la liberté qu'on
peut quitter sa religion
vous critiquez beaucoup cette femme qui
est très menacé m zineb elle est très
menacé pas la seule à la criée et vous
en rajoutez toujours sur elle compte
elle non mais non mais c'est terrible ce
que vous avez sur elle alors maintenant
que les menaces et le fait qu'elle soit
menacé nevoux l'arthrite la rue en
permanence le câble générer tant qu'elle
tiendra des propos islamophobes je
continuerai homophobes et l'éco système
politique on
nicolas au fond du poignant mais fitch
pleurer non mais non j'ai juste une
chose entre eux si je peux parler voilà
paysage puis il faut il faut arrêter
c'est pas parce qu'elle est menacée que
zineb est il que dire n'importe quoi
il suffisait mais je continuerai à la
jolie qui est à mes yeux ce porteur mais
qu'elle tiendra dans les fonctions au
sein de la sphère médiatique des propos
qui portent atteinte aux cowboys qui
milite dans l'eure
on sait d'ailleurs si elle a refusé
d'isoler une expression est bonne pour
halo si je peux répondre peu c'est que
bien évidemment liberté d'expression
mais en revanche c'est vous qui est
terrible ce que je trouve terrible c'est
vous qui en ferme et les musulmans dans
la solidarité avec l'islam politique
c'est à dire que toute personne
vous ne savez pas dissocier ce qui est
la critique qui serait insupportable des
musulmans les français musulmans sont
comme les français catholiques juifs
athées agnostiques tout ce qui vole
ils sont libres de pratiquer leur foi
dans le respect et la france leur permet
de faire cela mais en revanche dès que
critiquent l'islam politique qui veut
imposer une loi politique contraire à
toute l'idée de la france où la religion
est soumise à la politique et c'est pas
la vie de la cité qui régit par l'islam
faisait là vous accusez disent comment
ces gens qui est l'islam politique en
france qui sont ces gens des frères
musulmans que vous représentez ça
l'affairé musulmans qu'ils prêchent la
haine dans les mosquées le jeu
représente vous avez l'impression
d'avoir un frère musulman en face de
vous vous sentez pas un peu ridicule
j'ai lu ce que l'ipad lire non mais
regardez ce qu'est un monde est calme et
pourtant vous avez évoqué le leader
charleville derrière 38 % des musulmans
se disent ne pas être charlie c'est le
même pourcentage dans la globalité de la
société française vous auriez dû élire
dans leur ensemble et pas vouloir les
tronquer maintenant 6 38% des personnes
n'ont pas envie d'être charlie si vous
vous êtes charlie vous devriez nous
accorder le droit de ne pas être mais
vous avez tout à fait le droit et
heureusement de ne pas être charlie ce
que je dis c'est qu'il ya eu des gens
qui ont été tués sur le sol français
ils ont pas été tuées au nom de ils ont
été tuées au nom d'un islam ne vient pas
la folie
en crever mais moi je me je me calme je
dis simplement je dis simplement que la
société française sera réconcilier la
simulation se fera l'intégration quand
on aura pas 27 % des musulmans de france
qui considère que la charia doit
s'appliquer au dessus de la loi
républicaine
mais quand l'ensemble mais ça a été dur
aussi pour les cas tony ça c'est dur
aussi je ne sentais pas une question de
les intégrer dans un pays qui est le nom
de gestion l'art en france est-ce que
vous messieurs je vis dans ma vie et je
suis chez moi mais je sais mais la
france est le pays de la liberté
d'expression et ce n'est pas parce que
vous êtes vous pratiquez votre foi
librement que vous devez l'imposer aux
autres et je vous ai imposé quelques
élus tous vody sud eric ne l'ont pas
c'est à dire que vous faites là m'a
laissé faire croire à tous - tic et la
magie impose des choses que je que je je
fais du prosélytisme que je veut
enfermer les communautés françaises en
lice et la danse vous avez raison là
dessus arrêté ma vie je n'ai pas dis ça
je dis en revanche que toute personne
qui critiquent l'islam politique qui ne
veut pas que la société française
bascule dans l'islam politique vous
l'accusez d'islamophobie
on peut être en désaccord avec une
idéologie religieuse sans être eu contre
les musulmans
e.on a c'est le miracle vers celle à la
gare dire le voile utilisée par les
particuliers vous l'avais dit dans votre
interview et l'amour je les y remettre
en cause c'est la laïcité parce que la
laïcité elle elle commande que la chaire
éthique rentrent pas dans la religion de
la religion repas dans la politique et
vos besoins vous dites il faut vous êtes
quasiment pas vous l'avez d'ailleurs
vous serez pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
signes ostentatoires de religion de
tourisme anpt doivent alors arrêtons les
jolies jambes au menu donc
avis aux doigts d'or vo d'eric naulleau
dans le la danse je suis dit nicolas
dupont aignan bien sûr ils reprochent à
une partie des musulmans de vouloir
placer lacharriere au dessus des lois de
la république
c'est exactement ce que vous proposez à
l' inverse c'est à dire que le porter le
voile dans l'espace public correspond à
un droit constitutionnel
vous voulez placer vos propres croyances
vos propres opinions
au dessus des lois de la république et
la laïcité donc ce que vous reprochez à
votre adversaire politique puisque vous
le définissez comme tête c'est
exactement ce que vous faites excusez
moi on est en france il ya une
constitution
il ya des droits vous n'allez pas dire
on va passer charest dit lis religieuse
dans les rues pour voir ces les femmes 6
à l'époque puisque c'est leur donneur
d'abord ici reprenons si vous avez
écouté ce que j'ai dis j'en étais très
générale et desservira d'unix compter
sur la rue j'ai dit que j'étais plutôt
sceptique et qu'il faudrait un
référendum n'est pas la même chose
deuxième qui même ce que j'ai dit sur
l'égalité sur l'égalité des femmes et
des hommes
je considère que la liberté de la femme
était essentielle et que être en france
la religion font la religion quelle
qu'elle soit doit respecter l'égalité
des femmes et des hommes et de la
liberté c'est qu'elles puissent le
porter monsieur c'est vous qui remettant
en cause la loi sur la laïcité c'est pas
les musulmans d'aller beaucoup de femmes
qui sont forcés de porter leur voile il
ya beaucoup de mes iraniens à ce célèbre
interview je peux finir là j'ai regardé
sur internet ce célèbre interview de
nasser grand leader arabe d'égypte qui à
un moment où on lui dit mais on va
porter le voile et où il éclate de rire
en disant mais comment imaginer on né en
comment imaginer qu'on oblige nos femmes
nos filles à porter le voile
et il part dans un éclat de rire euh y'a
donc c'est pas un problème vis-à-vis des
musulmans dans tout les pays musulmans
il ya la volonté de garder une liberté
après que lier l'islam une religion
respectable eux que chacun pratique dans
le respect de la france comme dans le
respect de la tunisie de bourguiba qui
avait d'ailleurs interdit le voile
donc ne s'est pas un problème vous le
plaquer comme une sorte de racisme et on
est raciste parce qu'on n'est pas
d'accord il veut lamamra
si vous écrivez vous dirigez morton je
suis pas islamophobe la réponse est non
l'excès c'est bon soit actuellement à
feu et à sang mais franchement je vois
pas en quoi allez vous devez kaka à
faire d'un concorde et daf interne ou la
concorde c'est qu'on va y mettre tous
dans le même avion que les religions
respecte la rédation voilà dupont aignan
puisque maintenant puisqu'il bien jolie
j'ai même dans ma ville on a inauguré
une salle de prière je veux dire qu'il
ya aucune volonté de se préciser
personnes la nuit on les rassemble et la
séparation
merci moi j'avais pas des français
séparer les inconvénients à la religion
juste bien que la communauté la
communauté nationale et yoplait nicolas
dupont aignan oui il fallait donc vous
présenter en 2022 or on n'en sait rien
du tout wells il ya deux ans ohlala
alors là je
il y en a qui sont heureux maintenant
mais c'est bien mais on verra si vous
avez en revanche les présidents andré
qui comme premier me bernard laporte
on verra où on en est pas là mélenchon
mais maintenant on en est là on en est
pas là non mais sérieux la nouvelle peut
faire un ami proche et vous dire ici
la seule chose suivante mais il fait
pour lui quand j'ai voulu dire c'est pas
le problème de moi le problème c'est
l'état du pays je maintiens que notre
pays est en mauvais état et qu on a une
obligation de réconcilier socialement
car on ne peut rien faire si les gens ne
peuvent pas vivre dignement dans leur
propre pays